c'est probablement l'un des smartphones
les plus intéressantes cette année alors
je vais tout vous expliquer on se parle
de hop là mais là on se parle de celui
là c'est le jeune phone 7 pro de asus on
part à taïwan on va voir les smartphones
du côté de taïwan avec cette très jolie
marque et asus qu'on connaît bien
évidemment sur plein d'univers notamment
sur les ordinateurs mais ils sont
également présents au niveau du
smartphone avec un modèle qui est
vraiment bien c'est le zen phone and
phone chez pas si vous avez connu une
faune si ces dernières semaines françois
nous on passe et des meilleures vous en
douterez sur neo cette sécurité des
quelques uns avant il ya cette année
avec son iphone c'est trop on parle bien
du modèle professionnel parce qu'il ya
eu un autre modèle qui n'était pas un
modèle professionnel
là c'est vraiment le modèle propos pâle
et bien asus pourquoi cette chose de
vachement intéressant c'est ça ça c'est
la caméra flip et cette caméra flip
aller vachement cool parce que l
différenciante pas si vous vous souvenez
mais remonte en 2019 en 2019 beaucoup de
constructeurs sont positionnés à voir
des grands écrans sans encoches pas de
bulle pas de points sont pas dans coche
rien de rien et en 2020 tout mon affaire
grand rétropédalage sans phase us asus
qui a gardé cette idée de ce grand écran
dégagé on qui est vraiment bien pour
tout ce qui est un autre aspect
multimédia gaming et pour réussir et
bien ils sont passés par ce système là
de la caméra flip à cette caméra flip
elle apporte quelque chose qui vraiment
bien ça vous permet d'avoir un trip
module photo à l'arrière mais vous avez
deux fait un triple module photo à
l'avant une combinaison qui est gagnante
est justement grâce à détailler tout de
suite parce que oui cet asus and phone 7
pro il a beaucoup davantage mais il a
également tous les inconvénients qui
vont avec
on va donc sur les détails et pour voir
en finale cet asus eee phone 7 pro est
fait pour vous s'il intéressant quels
sont ses points forts et qu'elles sont
aussi ses points faibles c'est un
smartphone qui est assez lourd il fait
230 grammes et je puis vous assurer que
par rapport à l'ensemble des smartphones
du marché
celui ci est lourd et quand même
vraiment vraiment assez lourd avec un
poids qui est plus porté sur l'avant du
smartphone à cause du module photo
module photo motors à l'intérieur donc
on a un poids qui est quand même
beaucoup plus prononcé ici sur l'avant
que de l'autre côté si vous craignez les
smartphones qui sont un peu lourd et
bien ce n'était pas celui ci qui est
fait pour vous c'est aussi un smartphone
car peu plus grand que les iphone si ce
qu'on avait l'année dernière
à côté de ça moi j'aime bien vraiment ce
grand écran complètement dégagé le fait
de ne voir absolument aucune
encoches c'est superbe pour l'expérience
pour regarder des films des séries pour
jouer c'est vraiment extrêmement
extrêmement bon ça c'est vraiment le
gros point positif il faut vraiment le
dire vous avez 6 sur le côté ça c'est
très cool
un bouton principal pour l'allumer et
l'éteindre qui fait office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous permet de
déverrouiller très rapidement vous posez
votre doigt dessus se déverrouille et ça
c'est très très très bien mais qui en
plus est complètement personnalisable il
vous suffit d'aller dans vos paramètres
vous allez dans avancé vous allez danse
marque kiwi c'est le smart qui il est
activé vous appuyé deux fois ça vous où
l'assistant google hop c'est ce qui est
paramétré tout de suite je peux aussi
choisir la personnalisation m'ouvrir une
application par exemple m'ouvrir chrome
ici double tap
cette fois ci ça mouvement google chrome
je peux également appuyé maintenir pour
venir l'éteindre mais également pour
réveiller l'assistant google si je le
souhaite voler objets s'appuyer google
assistant je vais vraiment ce que je
veux ça s'est vraiment bien haut niveau
l'expérience de pouvoir venir
personnaliser son bouton principal c'est
très rare vous allez retrouver ensuite
sur le dessus vos boutons de volume qui
se situe juste là après rien à nos
connaît l'histoire haut parleurs de la
recharge en usb c'est le micro si ça
c'est une led de notification
c'est plutôt bien et aller planquer là
votre tiroir de cartes sim qui est caché
juste ici avec double net de signe +
carte micro sd peut monter jusqu'à 2
terrain au niveau du stockage et au
dessus vous avez ici un petit micro pour
la réduction de bruit et vous voyez à
l'arrière vous et votre module photo
avec pas moins de trois caméras je
voulais détaillé dans quelques instants
un dos qui du coup n'a pas de capteur
d'empreintes digitales
on a un dock y est légèrement incurvé un
écran qui est lui par contre est
complètement plat vous avez un écran de
6,67 pouces c'est vraiment très très
très grand un écran amoled qui dit
amoled de samsung parce que oui amoled
c'est le lait mais amoled c'est une
marque qui appartient à samsung un écran
vingt neuvième avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 heures ce sens
assez intéressant 90e parce que si vous
regardez ce que fergus et notamment au
niveau des smartphones de gaming ils
font le rock von anhalt dernier rock
funk est lui par contre un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 hertz on aurait
pu se dire effectivement là dessus asus
nous aurait proposé sur son iphone 7 pro
un taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
pour se mettre un peu au niveau des
autres mais n'ont pas fait en écran qui
est assez lumineux hdr disent plus enfin
vraiment très bel écran très belle
expérience pour tout ce que tu as fait
multimédia c'est vraiment très très bien
là dessus
à des haut parleurs stéréo j'arrête le
son haut parleur stéréo avec un son qui
part par là et le son qui vient du petit
haut-parleur qui planquaient ici en
façade on n'a pas la même directivité du
son un peu sur le côté un peu face à
vous néanmoins ça rajoute un peu à
sensation d'immersion et ça ira très
bien et notamment pour des parties goût
pour regarder des films et des séries et
leur attention
ne poussez pas trop fort sera tendance
un petit peu à venir saturé on reste sur
un smartphone donc rien de bien étonnant
là dessus ici néanmoins vous avez du
bluetooth 5.1 pour venir utiliser avec
un casque sans fil ça marchera bien
petite différence que vous avez par
rapport aux iphone 6 de l'année dernière
et bien vous n'avez pas de prise jack
elle a été supprimée alors asus nous
explique que c'est à cause d'un manque
de place nouveau processeur on avait un
dragon 865 plus je vous en parle dans
quelques instants de la place est prise
par le processeur est également par la
batterie parce que vous avez une très
grosse batterie de 5 millions par année
je vous en parle également dans quelques
instants
donc il ya plus la place pour mettre
cette prise jack
c'est un peu dommage à côté de ça et si
on regarde vraiment ce qui se passe au
niveau de la concurrence sur les
smartphones haut de gamme très haut de
gamme et ultra haut de gamme et bien les
prises jack disparaissent de plus en
plus ne reviennent pas elles sont
présentes uniquement dans l'entrée et le
milieu de gamme donc bon ce que fait
asus là dessus c'est pas surprenant que
c'est ce qu'on trouve classiquement chez
les concurrents comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure
asus a un autre smartphone c'est un
smartphone de gaming c'est le roquefort
alors le rock food c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui est assez incroyable en
termes de performance c'est de la
performance brute c'est une grosse
grosse grosse grosse machine de compet
et là en fait ils ont vraiment garder la
même formule c'est à dire le dernier
cela dragon 865 plus c'est aujourd'hui
le processeur le plus puissant du marché
couplé à 8 gigas de ram la techno c'est
également la plus puissante actuellement
c'est la lpddr2 5 et au niveau du
stockage lecture écriture on à ce qui se
fait mieux si tout de suite c'est de lui
fs 3.0 dont vous dire qu'on a un combo
gagnant qui fait que votre smartphone
est extrêmement performant et ira
parfaitement bien pour déjà ouvrir
toutes vos applications également pour
des sessions de 10 me ça sera
extrêmement fluide ah oui et d'ailleurs
vous avez 256 go de stockage je vous dis
pouvait monter jusqu'à 2 terrain grâce à
une carte microsd déjà 256 gigaoctets de
stockage je ne sais pas si vous allez
remplir je n'imagine pas ficher les
remplir un autre point sur lequel ce
smartphone est bon c'est l'autonomie
asus a fait le choix d'être une très
très grosse batterie de 5000 millions
père heures à l'intérieur ça vous
permettra de tenir une journée
deux jours bien évidemment une fois de
plus en fonction de vous de vos usages
si vous êtes extrêmement vraiment une
journée usage modéré normal une journée
et demie puisage vraiment cool de jours
sans problème mais maintenant il ya un
autre point qui est assez intéressant
sur lequel asus a fait un gros focus et
bien c'est vous avez une vraie bonne
gestion logicielle de votre batterie
alors avant de vous parler de ça et vous
le montrer il faut savoir qu'ici vous
avez un bloc de charges de 30 watts
c'est parce qu'être plus rapide
aujourd'hui surtout avec une grosse
batterie de 5000 militants pérore il
faudra donc vous armer de patience pour
venir recharger vous faudra plus d'une
heure pour recharger de 0 à 100% mais
heureusement asus a tout prévu
au niveau logiciel et ça vous allez voir
c'est très très très malin dans vos
paramètres vous allez dans batterie et
dans batterie c'est plutôt bien fait
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est les
modes de batterie ici je vois que j'ai
un mode équilibré si je veux aller plus
haut en termes de performances et bien
voulu se demander les meilleures
performances et rafraîchissements le
plus élevé ça va consommer davantage la
batterie je puisse y avoir un mode
économie d'énergie pour consommer
beaucoup moins si je souhaite
j'ai un mode super économie si vraiment
on tâche de me déconnecter d'internet
jeu plus à grand chose mais par contre
il s'est dit très très très sain on va
absolument pour rien on va se remettre
là pour y avoir quelque chose et après
je peux avoir deux modes personnalisés
en choisissant vraiment ce que je veut
activer désactiver la 5g ou pas lors la
5g elle est activée mais en fait elle
n'est pas activé parce que oui ça son
jeu n'est pas d'abonnement 5 g on
suspend vraiment venir complètement
paramétrer taux de rafraîchissement
réduction de luminosité délai avant
veille enfin tout ça vraiment
extrêmement mal un très très très bien
vu de la part d'asus j'ai aussi toute la
gestion jeu peut commuter pour mon
alimentation passé à économie d'énergie
lorsque la batterie est inférieure à 15%
c'est vraiment bien c'est très très bien
et je peux également commuter en me
disant par exemple que deux j'en sais
rien moi je me couche à l'air va dire à
23 ans je dors de 23h à 7h du matin je
ne l'utilisent pas eh bien je passais en
économie d'énergie pour que mon
smartphone soit vraiment au minimum et
consomment le moins de voix c'est ce
qu'ils sont très très malin j'ai ensuite
ou l'entretien de la batterie ici que je
vois que j'ai un entretien qui est très
très bon je peux aussi lui demander de
faire une charge lente pour vraiment
venir protéger ma batterie si je le
souhaite je peux y avoir une charge
planifié c'est à dire que mon smartphone
je peux le brancher par exemple le soir
quand je me couche mais c'est pas très
bon pour ma batterie qu'il se charge
tout le temps c'est pas la bonne idée je
peux malgré tout le brancher et dire par
exemple qu'il faut aller une grosse
heure et demie pour s'en charger moi je
me lève à 7h je peux dire qu'il prend la
charge à 5h30 jusqu'à 7 heures du matin
comme ça je suis vraiment optimales et
ça marchera très très très bien et je
peux également venir limiter la charge
en disant c'est pas la peine de le
charger à 100% je pilote pendant que je
me charge à 80 % ou à 90% pour une fois
de plus
venir protéger ma batterie et augmenter
sa durée de vie dont vous voyez il ya
plein de petits paramètres qui sont très
très sympa qui ont vraiment un sens qui
sont très très très juste
alors après si on vient fouine est un
petit peu dans les paramètres on voit
qu'on a quasiment à faire un android
stockent android 10 on a ici des nuages
cette si vous avez vraiment l'expérience
quasiment pur sang pour sang android eh
bien vous ne serez absolument pas
perturbé et maintenant on arrive dans
l'un des points forts de smartphones en
tout cas une des valeurs les plus fortes
qu'on va voir c'est au niveau de la
photo ce que nous propose asus un triple
module photo et surtout un triplement du
photos qu'on peut venir bouger comme on
le souhaite de façon extrêmement simple
ça c'est super pour venir l'inquiéter
comme vous le souhaitez vous avez trois
modes le premier mode on lève un petit
peu beaucoup moyennement c'est vraiment
bien puisqu'on a une précision de 0 5°
autant vous dire que c'est extrêmement
précis mais moi je trouve ça vraiment
juste hyper hyper hyper malin parce que
c'est à la fois votre caméra à l'arrière
à la fois venir faire des grands
panoramas très simplement en posant
votre smartphone et puis surtout
aujourd'hui c'est le seul smartphone
avec une triple caméra de celle fille on
va pouvoir retrouver effectivement une
caméra 64 mégapixels mais je vais vous
détaille dans quelques instants en
caméra principale en caméra de celle
fils est la seule qui en a pas d'autre
c'est vraiment super à la fois un ultra
grand angle pour venir vous prendre vous
et tous vos amis et à la fois un
téléobjectif alors vous me direz le
téléobjectif pour vous prendre en photo
comme ça ça n'a pas forcément trop
d'intérêts donc vous voulez jouer à
james bond voulait photographier
carrière vous lever comme ça vous mettez
hop le téléobjectif
et puis vous venez vraiment journée sur
les gens derrière pour me regarder ce
qui se passe pour devenir espionnes et
si vous le souhaitez mais au-delà de ce
côté un peu espions et d'un pouvait
venir voir ce qu'il ya dans votre nez
basse voulait venir avoir un terrain est
ce que mon nez est-ce qu'il faut que je
m'épile le nez ou par yao plat leurs
gardes
voilà ça me semble plutôt pas mal donc
vous avez quand même beaucoup de
possibilités ça ouvre un peu des usages
et surtout ça vous donne le meilleur en
termes de qualité que ce soit pour de la
photo ou pour la vidéo parce que oui on
peut être sûr on peut faire de la vidéo
jusqu'en 8 cas à 30 images par seconde
l'idée c'est pas forcément de faire de
la 8 cas aujourd'hui parce que vous
n'êtes pas forcément diffuser de la nuit
cas aujourd'hui
dans tous les cas vous allez avoir ce
qui est mieux pour venir faire vos
photos c'est super bien très bien pensée
très malin alors après le point peu
négatif de ça c'est qu'effectivement eh
bien on a un moteur ici l'eau pourrait
saisir moteur fragilité peut-être
peut-être pas a priori non parce que si
l us continue après avoir fait les
iphone 6 déjà avec ce système de moteur
même si on a un nouveau moteur mais je
vous
pendant quelques instants et bien c'est
que le système fonctionne le système est
prouvée plutôt bien vu et 1 c'est malin
maintenant le point négatif on va
retrouver ici à cause de ce moteur est à
cause de ce système c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui peut absolument pas être
certifié étanche à la poussière
également à l'eau voilà peut pas tout
avoir
on a des avantages qui sont très très
fort on a également des inconvénients
pas de certification est un smartphone
qui malgré tout reste assez lourd ça
vous permet d'avoir une caméra de cette
fille de 64 mégapixels salah sony mx 686
couvre f 1.8 avec une stabilisation
optique un ultra grand temps de 12
mégapixels c'est la soigner mix 363 que
vous ref 2.4 c'était le capteur
principal que vous aviez sur les iphone
5 qui vous servira notamment pour les
seuls faits le groupe et vous avez
également un des objectifs de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 avec un
zoom optique x 3 est un jeu hybride x 12
asus a changé le moteur de son module
photo il va être 40% plus petit et
surtout deux fois plus puissant on a
également un module anti gravité ce qui
fait que si vous échappez votre
smartphone et bien le module photo va
rentrer directement un bambin de toucher
le sol donc ça c'est aussi assez
rassurant et asus nous annonce résistant
jusqu'à 2 106 1000 cycles pour être très
précis
côté logiciel vous pouvez venir
paramétrer l'ouverture de votre caméra
regarder ce que appuyé hop là sur le
bouton home l'ouvrir un petit peu si je
le souhaite comme ça pour revenir
vraiment filmer le ciel je peut l'ouvrir
un tout petit peu moins je vais ma 90°
comme ça et j'ai également un réglage
vers le bas pour l'ouvrir un petit peu
moins je dois être à l'ordre de 2 45
degrés point qui est assez bien pensé de
la part de vue tu vas voir ici un petit
trou est en fait ce petit trou c'est mon
micro pour venir capter le son lorsque
je vais filmer quelqu'un il faut savoir
que j'ai en tout pas moins de trois
micros sur ce smartphone regardez ma ce
résultat des photos prix grâce à ce
smartphone je trouve vraiment pas mal
capteur principal on a très très bien
les nuages tous les détails on voit bien
les zones un peu plus drôme à ça c'est
très très cool c'est vraiment bien on se
rapproche tout doucement tout doucement
je trouve que le résultat est assez
bluffant est une très très belle
maîtrise heures dès qu'on se rapproche
au maximum forcément on va venir perdre
ça vient le lycée c'est pas terrible
mais malgré tout reconnaissez quand même
que l'exercice est vraiment bien l'ultra
grand pan est aussi bien pas déformant
il ya vraiment très très très beau
travail qui a été fait là dessus par
asus en continuant se balade dans paris
même avec le soleil joyau n'arrive bien
avoir le bâtiment voit bien les nuages
rien et cramer tout est juste c'est
vraiment très très bien l'ultra grand
pan il sera quand même assez efficace
dès lors vous
de la lumière on se rapproche on vient
vous mais toujours pareil vers l' afp ça
fonctionne on se met sur l'ultra grand
angle le boulot est fait corrects même
sur les petites parts de qualité mais ça
c'est normal c'est dû à ultra grand
angle zoom c'est bien décollé trop
proche c'est moins bien même lorsque
vous avez moins de lumière dans le métro
eh bien voyez les faits plutôt bien
alors moins de lumière tout de suite
lutra grand danger quand même beaucoup
moins bien ça ramène beaucoup de bruit
c'est tout de suite beaucoup moins
terrible mais bon on vous m'en voyez on
perd un peu en qualité c'est un peu
moins terrible moi personnellement je
suis assez fan assez convaincus du
résultat faut que vraiment là-dessus ils
ont très très bien bossé et surtout le
fait que vous puissiez retrouver
directement votre capteur principal en
captant ses fils est vraiment bien leur
pareil là en mode portrait là j'avais
vraiment pas mis trop trop trop de flou
je les pousser davantage sa me des tours
très très bien les doigts merci
effectivement a toute la capacité de
calcul du temps dragonne 865 plus qui
marche parfaitement bien lasser des
photos prises en conditions de faible
luminosité avec le mode nuit ça me faire
sortir tous les traits ça vient tirer
davantage ça me rajoute un espèce de
bruit chromatique au niveau des cheveux
c'est pas terrible mais par contre on
vient vous prendre en photo en mode
selphy avec votre caméra de 64
mégapixels ça marche très très bien avec
l'ultra grand temps que ça fera aussi
est là pour vous prendre vous et vos
amis par contre effectivement il faut
beaucoup lumière des vous êtes un petit
peu moins tout de suite la qualité est
moindre et pour venir vous voir de
beaucoup plus près grâce au téléobjectif
ça c'est bien aimé venir chercher
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus loin on
peut le faire on perd en qualité
elle n'est pas en quoi on peut le faire
on a tout de ce qu'on peut attendre d'un
smartphone haut de gamme en 2020 du nfc
du wifi 6 un grand écran haut parleurs
de qualité beaucoup de performances
beaucoup de polyvalence et notamment
photo et ça une fois de plus c'est
vraiment bien moi ça smartphones que
j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la
proposition maintenant le petit bémol
que j'ai effectivement c'est que c'est
malgré tout un smartphone qui reste
lourd et ça aujourd'hui
bon l'innovation est là l'innovation et
bien mais elle a aussi ses travers
on est rapidement vous ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par ce smartphone là avec
ce module photo est ce que vous le
feriez confiance ou pas du tout dit le
mandant commentait pas vraiment ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous avez acheté le zune
phone 6 mai dernière et est ce que ce
gène phone 7 pourrait vous rassurer ou
alors pas du tout est-ce que vous
sentiriez à l'aise justement avec un
module photo qui bouge comme ça peut
bouger à votre convenance
ça c'est vraiment qu'elles sont
extrêmement importante parce qu'on va
surtout alex ce smartphone pour ça parce
que ce module photo vous dégage d'écran
et qu'il apporte aussi bien bénéfices
que quelques côtes un peu négatif dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en banque au
mental et quant aux prix c'est un
smartphone qui coûte 799 euros
d'ailleurs si vous intéresse vous a mis
un lien en bas dans la description c'est
donc un smartphone très particulier qui
a les inconvénients de ces avantages
en tout cas j'aime bien la copie et je
salue vraiment asus d'être resté sur
cette idée du grand écran complètement
dégagée en 2020 c'est un pari c'est un
pari osé
il reste dans la continuité ce qu'ils
ont commencé à faire en 2019 et en plus
derrière il ya toujours plus de
performances des meilleurs qualité photo
enfin voila moi j'aime beaucoup et je
trouve que l'idée vraiment rare et très
très très mal il n'attend je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde aille se ruer
dessus mais est ce que c'est vraiment la
stratégie d'asus sais pas ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire on se
retrouve extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer par les textes parce que oui
parce que oui elle la tête ne s'arrête
pas et ça c'est super on des bisous de
l'amour a très vite qu'un
[Musique]